Leslie is with us in Kansas City hi
Leslie how are you I'm great Dave how
are you better than I deserve what's up
well I first I'm grateful for you
because a year ago I bought Financial
Peace University my husband and I went
through it and we have just become very
intentional this year and so I want to
thank you for that so my question is I
would like to understand stock market
volatility in retirement a little better
because we've been watching the stock
market go up and down this year and we
take your advice nobody gets hurt until
they hop off the roller coaster so we're
just staying on and saying we but when
when someone's in retirement and that is
happening how do you handle that because
if there are no eggs coming out of the
geese that year do you have to kill a
goose or how do people plan for that in
retirement well let's just use a short
term example but apply it across 20
years in retirement okay but let's say
in 2017 the stock market the S&P 500
one-up 19.7% okay
top up this year as of today word about
a break-even really hasn't a loss thing
hadn't made any okay I don't know what
will be out by calendar you're in but
usually we'll see a push in December so
that it'll probably make something but
it's not gonna make 19 percent so let's
say we get to the year end of 2018 and
the stock market makes 4% this year last
year made 19 okay and you are set up to
pull off 8% okay I'm just making up a
number then that's think that's the eggs
you're pulling out 8% of eggs but right
last year you know that would have left
you 11 in there 19 minus 11 right okay
this year you're going to pull off out a
forward but you're gonna pull out 8
you're gonna pull out an extra 4 so
you're taking that a little chunk out of
but the goose was 11 percent bigger last
year after you dropped her off so on
average across those two years you're
still ahead that makes sense yeah so you
know one year even though one mounting
cash yeah so you just set up you set a
percentage of your nest egg that you
want to live on and it should be below
average stock market returns if you're
invested in good mutual funds and I
assume you are because that's how you're
asking this question so so what is the
size of your nest egg so right now we're
not close to the time and I'm 46 my
husband is 44 okay so this is
theoretical so how much is in your nest
egg now well we've got about 600 right
now okay well let's pretend that you are
a couple of years along and you've got a
million and a half okay ten percent one
hundred fifty thousand dollars a year
right right and what's your household
income right now about two hundred okay
all right and so you know you can
probably make it pretty good on 8% of a
million and a half you ever take and as
long as your returns are averaging more
than 8% I like to say 8% plus four for
inflation but so 12% you know if you use
6% I don't care but whatever number you
want to use that you're gonna live off
of it has to be less than average stock
market returns and then some years you
might cut into it other years you might
replenish some years you might cut into
it other years you might replenish but
if it a verge is 12 and you're pulling
off six all on average you're going to
grow over a period of five or ten 20
years it's going to grow if you're only
pulling off half of what the returns are
but in a given year or a given month you
might be cutting in to some of the other
years excess returns and that's how your
law of averages works out